head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard
charts you know I I I grew up in Chicago
everybody knows Urban liberal story and
all that stuff and we we hated this idea
of judging someone based on the color of
their skin instead of the content of
their character amen I go to New York
City at the start of occupy Wall Street
they started Luke was there too so Luke
definitely knows this they started off
with something they called the general
assembly where everybody would sit down
and they would all you know raise their
hands to speak and then they would do
twinkle fingers they called it if you if
you liked cuz clapping was offensive to
people who couldn't hear or whatever
they had something called Progressive
stack that meant if you raised your hand
to speak but you're a white man bottom
of the list because white men are
privileged so they would actually look
at people and say can I get anybody
who's not a white man you can't speak
and if you look like one you'd have to
shout out something about why you were
actually a minority I knew there was one
instance where a guy raises his hand and
they go anybody who's not a white man
and he goes I'm gay and they go okay you
can talk now that that qualifies one of
the most shocking things I ended up
seeing which is a real wakeup call for
me was when they created something
called the spokes Council this is where
they decided the general assembly is
inefficient let's have a better more
efficient model of decision-making by
breaking everyone up into different
groups based on the job you do if you
work on the website you're part of a
website group if you work on cleaning
sanitation you're sanitation group and
of course let's have a group for black
people a group for only Asian people a
group for only Mexican people a group
for only women and they actually decided
to have political voting power on
resources based on your race or sex and
then there was a moment one day I'm
walking on the side of zucati Park and
there was a black man sitting up on this
planner and he said these people are
nuts what do you think the Press is
going to say when they find out they're
segregating everybody based on race to
make their decisions but they just
destroyed their own movement I mean I
was I'll be honest I was I was annoyed
by Occupy Wall but I was kind of
sympathetic to the core idea that you
have this massive series of financial
crimes in ' 08 and not one person is
punished and that actually the real scam
is economic they're they're looting the
country and someone needs to call out
the banks on this in finance World in
general Occupy Wall Street was totally
eclipsed by identity politics which I
believe was you know the antidote like
the banks got together and the people
who benefit from banks are like oh let's
just put them together based on race
like this is a widely held Theory but
for the occup Wall Street people
themselves to be embracing identity
politics undercuts their whole argument
it was subversion it was subversion I I
I met Luke there and you ask yourself
everybody everybody here knows Luke how
how does someone like Luke Luke and I
come together and it's because
originally it was exactly as you
described yeah it was people from the
left it was people from the right there
was daily marches against the US Federal
Reserve there was a lot of Libertarians
there's a lot of people who were
representing the larger ideas of the Tea
Party a lot of ROM politics and then and
then this coalition of individuals from
the left and right scared the crap out
of this then they sent in crazy people
that's how I got to know Tim because me
and Tim were at these no we were at
these spokes Council meetings and we
were like these people have lost their
freaking minds they're freaking insane
they weren't here on day one they came
in here and they're literally saying
black people got to stay here white
people have to stay here we're like this
is this is this is stupid this
makes no sense at all unless you're
trying to subvert and destroy it from
the inside and I think that's exactly
what happened and then the corporate
said we got obsess about race because
this is how you destroy populist
movements and this is why we keep
talking about race over and over again
when it's the simplest stupidest thing
that should have of course not be a
major issue we should be talking about
the larger better things and the are
more amazing things in life not just a
superficial that doesn't matter
I told Steve Benn and I wish he came to
Occupy Wall Street and and and helped
because that first week was so different
from what it turned into there were I I
remember meeting you know a couple and
they were they were in their 6 with an
American flag and they were upset about
the bank ballots and this and subversion
and I think what happens is it's very
easy for liberals to infiltrate in a
city like New York and it's very
difficult for conservatives to to stand
their ground in such a place and it's
not a theory Tucker I mean you can see
that the people that run Wall Street
they love the woke stuff like Larry fank
because then we never talk about income
inequality or wealth in the woke smoke
screen is is a protection racket for
them and they're paying half the taxes
yes I mean like why does no why did no
one I mean why is it twice as virtuous
to invest as it is to go to work every
day we tax the things we want to
discourage and we don't tax the things
we want to encourage that's why
cigarettes are so expensive so if you're
taxing investing at half the rate as you
are working what you're telling me is
it's twice as virtuous to invest but is
it I don't know that it is I kind of
admire people who go to work every day
like what what is this and it's not even
typical investing right let's be honest
this is this is maass this is using
other people's money OPM like hard by by
the way they're using Labor's money
Tucker as you know they're using teacher
and firefighter and police officer money
and getting 3% management fees and 30%
of The Upside by the way they don't pay
any tax on any of the earning they just
say oh you know we can't get rid of the
carried interest loophole and they have
this whole insane tax scheme designed
and I just I I wonder what wealth are
they actually creating or are they just
moving trillions of dollars of money
through a cheap kind of a cheap
instruments and taking taking 3% 4% off
the top but the woke this is what's
important we have to realize it Occupy
Wall Street was so scary to them because
it was diverse because it was bipartisan
is that they H know Tim do you actually
think that Goldman Sachs said go send in
the identity politics people I believe
it like do you think that there was a
meeting at Goldman Sachs where they said
go bring in the NYU trans like race
people to go distract them from talking
about Bank bailout not Goldman Sachs
whatever but uh powerful political
interest s this is a fact there were
people who were on salary at large
Progressive nonprofits who were at
Occupy Wall Street on paper getting
money from a nonprofit and paychecks and
the funny thing is when this was
accurately reported and sometimes
inaccurately reported they'd say there
the people down there are getting paid
by insert nonprofit who receives money
from St George Soros all the activists
would go I didn't get my Soros check and
I'm like dude John over there works for
this nonprofit that is literally a
progressive voter registration nonprofit
and he's organizing the assemblies right
now yes that is literally happening and
so perhaps it was as simple as hey guys
here's an opportunity we better harness
it and it and it and it bums me out to
think the reality of Occupy Wall Street
was progressives being smarter and
faster than the populist right and you
you look at the stated positions of like
the open Society Foundation George Soros
it conveniently ignores wealth
inequality income inequality home
ownership it's like open borders and
racial transformation and trans stuff
it's like wait hold a second George
Soros are you afraid that there might be
a real movement to go take and tax your
20 billion Foundation that doesn't pay
any taxes and is being used to you know
subvert and infiltrate the country
country but I think what has happened is
especially post Floyd is that every
major company is fine doing a $50
million check to some CRT Dei company as
long as we don't talk about the fact
that young people can't buy homes Larry
thinkink is terrified that this audience
or just Republicans Democrats young
people all across the country will unite
and lock arms and say why is it that we
can't buy homes and we're talking about
you know people's pronouns yeah that's
right can sure I I I just want to say
this before you jump in uh I firmly
believe and you know I've changed my
positions uh obviously since I first
started with political commentary like
10 years ago I used to be just a very
like Diehard uh total free market guy
and I've moved on that I believe
property rights are extremely important
but part of the reason that I believe
that that's true is because people who
own property are a lot more difficult to
control and push around and the issue
with Communism and the issue with Hyper
capitalism even though they express
themselves very differently and even
though under communism you have many
horrific instances of people being
slaughtered uh I don't mean to down
plainy that but one of the the same
economic issues you see with both of
those is that all of the property ends
up centralized in the hands of a small
group of people who have control over it
so of course uh in communist country
that's the party members and in a
capitalist country that doesn't have the
proper regulations in place that's the
capitalist class and your average person
ends up without property so what we need
to do is structure our regulations so
that the largest number of people
possible can own property I think that's
the way that you have a flourishing
system I'm hopeful if you own nothing
you're not going to be happy no right
it's the opposite of what the world
economic Forum says what the world
economic Forum uh princi the principle
they're operating under is actually
derived from a quote from Harriet Tubman
I freed many slaves I would have freed
many more If Only They knew they were
slaves the inverse is what the world
economic Forum wants to introduce take
from them the knowledge of their freedom
and they won't miss
it are people so pissed off is the
pendulum now swinging in the other
direction yes cuz that's what I'm seeing
yeah that's why they have to indict
Trump right because for years the media
could just say this person's racist this
person sexist this person's homophobic
and that was enough to destroy that
person's career but it didn't destroy
Trump and so because the media no how no
longer has the ability to shut people up
the state actually has to come in and
shut people up and you're right it's
making people angry stuff is not just in
um IBM it's in everywhere y I'm getting
the messages from all the people inside
all the companies so it feels like
whatever pressure it was to adopt the
Dei now it's just the pendulum swung is
that happening it's The Bravery I mean
how about we just talk about the hard
numbers of these Disney movies and what
do they lose a billion dollars in their
last releases the latest Marvel movie
was the lowest grossing out of anything
that they've done so far yeah get what
go broke can we get a round of applause
for
that Disney lost a billion dollars on
its films on on I think what is it the
last 10 films lost a collective billion
the the latest MCU movie was which was
the Marvels was a was lower grossing
than the Incredible Hulk in 2008 which
is considered to be their worst I think
people are just saying we'll find
something else we're done with it it's
kind of remarkable that some of the
greatest victories come from people just
being like I'm leaving it just that
simple yeah they just say I'm not going
to look you know what I always used to
say whenever they would make these video
games that were all woke or whatever I'd
say hey that's great I'm really happy
for you that you got your video with
your video game with the pinked woman
I'm not going to buy it you know but you
do your thing and then it turns out
nobody else wanted to buy it either but
so James you have other companies
reaching out to you yes constantly you
usually on Signal or on our website just
non-stop Banks institutions I mean I
prefer video because I think documents
are not as powerful but it's non-stop it
just seems like it takes one and then
Crescendo you and you know this just
give them a camera and have them ask the
HR person about the document right then
you get a video like I have a mortgage I
have a wife I have a kid this it's it's
always these convers how do you respond
to that it's tough I mean I I it's I
don't have a mortgage and kids not yet
but it's tough to empathize um the the
one individual was very uh inspired by
that one clip you talking about very
powerful the pastor was Minister it was
a minister talking to me about how
afraid he was he should resign from the
minister I'm not a I don't I'm not
qualified to to advise the minister and
I said to the person what I say is
what's the worst thing that can happen
to you if you tell the truth and he goes
gee I I never thought about it that way
and this individual with an IBM had seen
that clip and also saw the Elon Musk you
know fub Bob speech and Elon Musk you
know IBM and Disney canceled advertising
and and the individual let's call them
IBM said what's the worst
thing that happened to me because
because because it kind of eats at you
if you're seeing something horrible and
you're go you're just doing the job for
the paycheck and the pension you know
the that just tears at your soul so
you're you're confronted with this
horrible decision I either do this job
and I can't live with myself or I tell
the truth and I lose my job and what I'm
seeing is the trajectory of people you
know what I'm going to tell the truth
and lose my job the worst thing that
could happen to you if you tell the
truth you'll be set free and and I feel
like AG I feel like Tucker and I that's
Christianity absolutely the truth will
set you free that's right the truth
shall set you free and sometimes the
worst thing being free is actually the
best thing but they don't see it that
way cuz got the mortgage and the job and
the roof and maso's hierarchy of needs
they have to have food shelter you know
Etc and it is and it is hard it is scare
I can respect that very difficult Doki
said uh your worst sin is that you have
destroyed and betrayed yourself for
nothing and when you when you think
about that quote you when you look at
the situation that a lot of people are
in they think they're making the right
decision for themselves and their
mortgages and their families right now
but but in reality they're making the
worst decision for their future for
their children for this country as a of
course all these little decisions
everyone's saying I'm just doing my job
that keeps adding to the initial
destruction as this country is being
sabotaged from within and it's only
being sabotaged with our acquiescence
with our participation in it with us
voting for it with us clicking and
liking and giving our money to these
creatures that serve essentially Satan
the these people don't serve you don't
care about you you you need to make sure
every dollar you spend goes towards a
good cause you need to download Public
Square and shop at businesses that
support your values our values and we'll
that's one simple simple way cuz maybe
all you're going to do is buy a you know
I don't know barbecue pulled pork but
you're supporting a company that
believes in this country I want to plug
something else something I just became a
member of and you guys should too and
Tucker you've had a crazy year Tucker
Carlson Network people can become
members too and get access to your
content thank you yeah I I want to build
something that can't be canceled but may
I say something about standing up and
you know taking the abuse for doing that
um I I do think it's high stakes for a
lot of people and all my kids are grown
and I've already been through the cycle
of you know being poor Rich poor You
Know Rich again um and so I don't find
that as scary but I do think if you've
got kids in the home it's it's scary I
mean it is is not a small decision to
make but I also think here's one
potential upside if you tell the truth
and stand on principle and you know act
in a dignified way as a man the people
around you want that women want that
they don't want to be married to was and
I I do think you know in the dynamic in
marriage especially with small children
in the home is you know don't screw it
up we've got you know a lot at stake we
you know we need the money and all that
but I think if you say calmly like you
know I my dignity requires me to tell
the truth you will get a lot of
understanding and I think long term your
wife will respect you more they want a
little fire in a man and your children
will respect you more and that is man
that is worth a lot I
think absolutely that's a very good
point and also the example that you're
setting for your children right cuz
they're going to grow up and they're
going to be faced with similar dilemas
yeah no one remembers the names of the
people who killed Jon of AR honestly to
to Pander to your Catholic sensibility
but no for no I mean you know she kind
of you wouldn't want to be burned to
death that's a kind of the last thing
you'd want on the other hand how' you
like to be you know Immortal for your
bravery mhm I don't know there there
there actually much worse things than
that and and living like a slave is one
of them thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net